I'm Ed Bertschinger, MIT'S
Institute, Community,
and Equity Officer.
It's my privilege to welcome
you to this community dialogue
responding to recent tragedies.
To introduce the event and to
prepare you for the work ahead,
I begin with a poem by
Juan Felipe Herrera,
Poet Laureate of
the United States,
called "@ the Crossroads,
a Sudden American Poem."
"RIP Philando Castile, Alton
Sterling, Dallas police
officers, Lorne Ahrens,
Michael Krol, Michael J. Smith,
Brent Thompson, and
Patrick Zamarippa,
and all their families.
And to all those injured.
Let us celebrate the lives
of all as we reflect and pray
and meditate on
their brutal deaths.
Let us celebrate those
who marched at night
and who spoke of peace and
chanted Black Lives Matter.
Let us celebrate the
officers dressed in blues,
ready to protect.
Let us know the departed
as we did not know them
before, their faces, bodies,
names, what they loved,
their words, the stories
they often spoke.
"Before we return to the
usual business of our days,
let us know their
lives intimately.
Let us take this moment
and, as impossible
as this may sound, let us
find the beauty in their lives
in the midst of their sudden
and never imagined vanishing.
"Let us consider the
Dallas shooter-- what
made him, what happened
in Afghanistan,
what flames burned inside.
Who was that man in Baton Rouge
with the red shirt selling
CDs in the parking lot?
Who was that man in
Minnesota toppled
on the car seat with
a perforated arm
and a continent-shaped flood
of blood on his white T?
Who was that man, prone and
gone by the night pillar of El
Centro college in Dallas?
This could be the first
step in the new evaluation
of our society.
This could be the first
step of all of our lives."
This is why we are here.
We were invited
by President Reif,
who sends his regrets that
he cannot be president
because of international travel.
But many of MIT's
senior leaders are here,
including Provost Marty Schmidt
and Chancellor Cindy Barnhart.
We are here in answer to
President Reif's call, when
he wrote, "I believe our
leading civic institutions have
a responsibility
to speak clearly
against these corrosive
forces, and to act practically
to inspire and create
positive change.
In this time of need,
the MIT community
has an opportunity to offer
service of great value
to our society, to our country,
and perhaps to the world
by applying our unique strengths
to the problem at hand.
But we are also here because of
our individual cries of pain,
pangs of fear, and desire
for peace and healing.
MIT prides itself on
its mind and hand.
Today, we are
exercising our heart.
"Our goal today is not
to solve a problem.
This event is not
about solutions.
We can't solve a problem we
can't hear each other talking
about.
We can't solve a problem we
can't hear each other talking
about.
First, we must listen to each
other with our whole hearts,
to feel, to cry, to
be held together.
"You will be
uncomfortable today.
If you're not uncomfortable,
we're not growing.
Stay with us.
Take strength from our students
who shared their vulnerability
in the MIT admissions blogs.
Read them, and share them
with your friends and family.
"Take strength in knowing that
everyone here-- faculty, summer
students, alumni, MIT police,
support staff-- everyone
is here to be together
in a caring community.
We care deeply, so deeply
that it sometimes hurts.
That is OK.
Pay attention now.
Here is the program.
After the next speaker, you will
focus on your table as a group.
Each table has a
facilitator who is
prepared to help work
with everyone to address
some questions of the heart.
Your facilitator will present
discussion ground rules
we invite you to respect.
You'll have until 1:20
PM to explore together.
There's no question and
answer to the whole group.
We're in four different rooms.
You will have a chance to
send notes and recommendations
to the organizers
by writing them
on index cards at each table.
We will collect these and share
a summary with the community
by early fall.
I want to give thanks to those
who made this event possible,
starting with President
Reif, whose passionate call
for a response to the
killings last week
has brought us together.
Thank you to Ted Johnson and his
big team at Institute Events,
and MIT Video Productions
for pulling together
a major event in one week.
Thank you to the working
group on support staff
issues for their volunteers.
And thank you to the many
facilitators serving today.
Thank you to Kirk
Kolenbrander, to Alice Johnson,
Abigail Francis, and La-Tarri
Canty, Kester Barrow,
[? Dianetta ?] [? Creighton. ?]
Please join me in thanking them
all.
[APPLAUSE]
After this event, we invite
you to a post-event time
for prayer and reflection
with Chaplain Andrew Innocent
in Room 491 upstairs, where you
can decompress and contribute
if you wish to an
art project called
"Thoughts from the Heart."
Now, it is my pleasure to
introduce MIT Area Director
Kester Barrow of the
Division of Student Life who
will offer some important
framing of today's
conversations.
Mr. Barrow.
[APPLAUSE]